so today we're going to talk about the
connection between the health of your
teeth
and the health of your heart there's a
huge connection
if you have problems in your teeth it
can more than
double the problems in your heart what
they found is some of the bacteria in
your teeth
are actually ending up in your heart so
let's say for example
i don't know you have some infection in
the gum or some infection underneath the
tooth
what happens is certain microbes and
here's one of them right here
strep gordoni can get into the
bloodstream
travel down to the heart and that
particular
bacteria can mimic a certain type of
protein
fibrinogen and that could lead to clots
now they're also finding microbes in
your teeth that are also showing up in
your
joints and then here's another microbe a
type of strep
viridance this was found in 84 percent
of stroke victims i'm going to put these
links down below
but i think it's fascinating that
microbes from your mouth are ending up
in different parts of your body
in certain pathological states and then
we have this other connection
we talk about vitamin k2 vitamin k2 is
all
about keeping your bones strong keeping
your teeth
strong and when you're missing k2
the calcium from your bones from your
teeth
travel over into the arteries into the
soft tissue into the joints
so people are deficient in k2 can end up
with more
calcified arteries and a lot of dental
problems i have some reality on this
growing up in the midwest
consuming a lot of carbohydrates and
sugar especially
refined sugars and i ended up with
cavities
in every single tooth i went to the
dentist
very very often and you know what i
craved as a child i
couldn't get enough of it butter
i remember consuming like sticks of
butter in one sitting
well guess where you get k2 and butter
it's also in liver it's also in egg
yolks
it's in certain cheeses you can also get
it in other things like fermented soy
products
but butter has a good amount of cake too
no wonder
i wanted butter the problem is
i didn't just eat the butter by itself i
had to eat it with
bread and other refined carbohydrates
and eventually caught up with me not
just the k2 but just sugar in general
what it did for my health
i hit my low point the worst point of my
health at age 28
i'm 29 now so i'm actually doing much
better but at 28 it was
really really bad what's the moral of
the story
don't eat sugar the sugar
feeds the microbes the microbes ferment
okay fermented sugar and they give off
an acid and they create all sorts of
destruction in your teeth
and the soft tissues around the teeth
and in the presence of sugar your body
cannot use vitamin c
vitamin c is necessary for the collagen
that holds the tooth
into the bone also as a really good
natural antibiotic you can use one or
more of these herbs
oregano is at the top of the list garlic
would be probably number two
thyme and cloves all of these are really
good as natural antibiotics
with no side effects especially if you
have some type of
infection systemically in your body but
of course
they won't work unless you change your
diet if you're new to my channel and you
don't know what i'm talking about i put
some links down below
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it